[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous et
bienvenue dans ce sens public 90 minutes
pour donner du sens à l'actualité et aux
crises que nous traversons et voici le
sommaire de ce 4 juillet Emmanuel Macron
a reçu aujourd'hui près de 250 mères de
communes frappée par les violences
urbaines le présent République pense que
le pic des émeutes est derrière nous
même s'il se dit très prudent l'heure
est au bilan un milliard d'euros de
dégâts pour les entreprises des
centaines de bâtiments publics saccagés
et déjà cette question que faire de plus
pour les quartiers défavorisés après 40
ans de politique de la ville on en débat
dans une minute et puis pour notre
second thème volontairement décalé de
l'actualité du jour on part vers le
Brésil pour voir s'il est espoirs nés du
retour de Lula au pouvoir ont été déçus
sur la guerre en Ukraine par exemple il
ne s'aligne pas sur la condamnation
occidentale de la Russie
les États-Unis doivent cesser
d'encourager la guerre et commencer à
parler de paix l'Union européenne doit
commencer à parler de paix afin de
convaincre Poutine et ski que la paix
est dans l'intérêt du monde entier
politique étrangère traité de
libre-échange avec l'Europe
déforestation de l'Amazonie recule de la
pauvreté Lula était très attendu après 4
ans de bolsonaro a-t-il tenu ses
promesses réponses dans trois quarts
d'heure mais d'abord le soutien de
l'État aux villes attaquée par les
émeutiers Emmanuel Macron a annoncé une
loi d'urgence pour accélérer les
reconstructions Cécile Sixou ils
immortalisent le moment
ils étaient près de 250 des mers venus
de toute la France
ont vécu des violons et des dégradations
dans leur commune et attendent des
réponses de l'État mais aussi une
reconnaissance de leur rôle par le
président qu'il reconnaisse l'importance
qu'on les met comme pilier de la
République quand on touche on aime
autant qu'on touche au fondement même de
la République à huis clos pendant près
de trois heures les édits ont eu
l'oreille d'Emmanuel Macron à la sortie
certains ont le sentiment d'avoir été
entendu je trouve que le Président de la
République a été à l'écoute a été a été
sincère pas échappé que ça a été une
méthode du président jusque là
d'organiser des débats etc bon moi je
sais ça passe c'est la démarche d'écoute
d'autres sont plus sceptiques et
dénoncent une réunion pour rien j’étais
quand même du président de la République
de donner une vision un cap nous dire
comment est-ce qu'on a les s'en sortir
et et avancer là aujourd'hui on a
strictement rien du donc je suis
extrêmement déçu quand on fait ce genre
de réunion de encore une fois de
psychothérapie en urgence pour
communiquer avant tout évidemment une
fois que le feu a pris on donne le
sentiment aux émeutiers que c'est
uniquement brûlant qu'on attire
l'attention sur les quartiers populaires
et c'est un vrai danger il faut être
capable de parler politique de la ville
et banlieue toute l'année tout le temps
est d'agir efficacement beaucoup de
merde on déploré l'abandon du plan Borlo
en 2018 il devait faire revenir la
République dans l'écartier
on parlait du on parle du rapport
Morlaix même si je pensais il est assez
ancien c'est vrai que depuis il n'y a
pas eu le même type d'exercices de
proposition venant du terrain je pense
qu'il faut s'inspirer de ce type de
méthode solution viendra pas d'en haut
plus exactement d'ici elles viendront du
terrain sans faire d'annonces concrètes
le président a tout de même évoqué des
pistes de travail notamment une loi
d'urgence pour reconstruire les
dégradations dans les communes touchées
ou encore une nouvelle étape de
décentralisation il a donné rendez-vous
au maire pour un point d'étape à la fin
de l'été
on peut considérer que cette loi
d'urgence pour accélérer à la
reconstruction est une annonce concrète
en y reviendra évidemment dans ce débat
c'est l'un l'une des informations
importantes de cette journée je vous
présente mes invités martial Foucault
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes directeur du
Sevi pof le centre de recherche de
Sciences Po Gaëlle Slimane président
co-fondateur de Loxam bonsoir bonsoir et
bienvenue j'accueille Richard Verly
bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue à vous
correspondant en France Europe pour le
média Suisse Blic Emily bonsoir Émilie
spécialiste en communication politique
et éditorialiste pour sens publique
martial Foucault on espère c'est ce que
disait le président de la République
avoir passé le pic des émeutes c'est
peut-être un peu tôt pour pour faire le
bilan mais quelle leçon vous tirez vous
quelles leçons principales si on avait
une seule quelle leçon vous tirer de de
cette semaine de violence urbaines
c'est difficile d'en tirer qu'une leçon
parce qu'on voit bien que les plus
celui des mers qui ont été en première
ligne durant durant ces 6 jours et
probablement que ce sujet n'est pas
nouveau on a vu des signaux depuis un
certain nombre de mois déjà de maire qui
n'ont pas dans l'agression physique mais
dans une montée des incivilités des
violences symboliques qu'il recevaient
il y a le sujet des maires il y a le
sujet de la politique des quartiers et
vous l'avez évoqué 40 ans politique de
la ville qui n'a pas donné au regard de
l'investissement financier considérable
les résultats escomptés ce qui veut dire
par là que c'est peut-être pas une
mauvaise politique de la vie qui a été
menée jusque là c'est tout simplement le
suivi de cette politique de la ville
parce qu'on a le sentiment quand même
depuis 40 ans quand on regarde
l'ensemble des programmes qui ont été
déployés il y a des réussites mais
finalement ce sont des réussites qui
ont
qui ont été construits sur
un mauvais diagnostic de ce qu'est la
politique de la ville puis un troisième
sujet je crois qui est important et le
fait que le Président de la République
reçoivent aujourd'hui les mers
c'est au fond peut-être essayer de
corriger une erreur qui depuis 2017 a
conduit Emmanuel Macron à ne pas
véritablement s'appuyer sur le rôle des
mers dans la vie pas simplement
démocratie mais dans la vie de ce qui
fait société au plan local et on voit
bien parce que l'erreur originelle parce
que ensuite il y a eu les gilets jaunes
il y a eu enfin il s'est retourné vers
les élus locaux mais vous dites que
c'est cette terreur originale elle lui
colle toujours au
vous avez raison il a il n'a pas
totalement éconduit les mers mais ils
sont simplement
rassemblés ils sont simplement écoutés
lorsqu'une crise
surgit et il y a pas d'anticipation avec
les miens je ne dis pas que les mers on
les réponses à tous les problèmes parce
que ce que l'on ne voit depuis plusieurs
jours ce sont des sujets qui dépassent
largement le champ de compétences des
maires et d'ailleurs moi je ferai une
distinction quand même entre les les
violences les dégradations dans des
petites communes dans les communes de
moins de 10000 habitants et dans des
agglomérations ou des métropoles on voit
bien que dans les agglomérations les
métropoles c'est un sujet de politique
de la ville dans les plus petites
communes c'est un autre sujet et que
Emmanuel Macron jusqu'à présent avait
écarté
d'évaluer à chaud les conséquences de de
ces images ultra-violence dans l'opinion
mais si on remonte en 2005 2005 ça avait
été trois semaines des meute et là bon
bah on a évidemment tout le recul
nécessaire pour l'analyser comment les
Français avaient réagi par une demande
d'ordre de sécurité plus de police
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que c'est réagir
un petit peu comme on le voit
aujourd'hui malheureusement on a
l'impression que c'est une ritournelle
que ça revient constamment ils avaient
agi d'une première manière parce que
vous vous souvenez qu'en 2005 il y avait
eu les propos de Nicolas Sarkozy disant
est-ce que vous voulez que je vous
débarrasse de cette bande de racailles
et ça avait mis le feu aux poudres et
dans les sondages de l'époque quand on
interroge les Français sur la posture de
Nicolas Sarkozy ministre de l'Intérieur
à ce moment là ils étaient
majoritairement hostiles ce qu'il avait
dit à ce qu'il avait fait et ça lui
avait coûté des points à court terme et
le paradoxe qui fonctionne j'ai regardé
pour un livre que j'écris il y a
quelques années dans plusieurs autres
pays en Russie au début de Poutine aux
États-Unis au moment des attentats du 11
septembre pour Georges de bolliouche en
Israël au moment d'Ariel Sharon à chaque
fois que vous incarnez une posture
d'autorité
même quand les résultats viennent
démentir votre posture d'autorité et que
les gens dans un premier temps se disent
bah ça n'a pas marché le simple fait
d'avoir la posture d'autorité même en
ayant de mauvais résultats vous
bénéficie structurellement et donc pour
répondre à votre question Nicolas
Sarkozy dans un premier temps ministre
de l'intérieur avec perdu des points il
avait même été obligé vous en souvenez
de laisser prendre le relais si j'ose
dire au Premier ministre à Dominique
Villepin et Ajac qui a un moment lui
avait dit bon on va pouvoir arrêter les
conneries si j'ose dire maintenant on va
gérer parce que c'est plus possible
résultat plus 17 en l'espace de deux ou
trois mois pour Nicolas Sarkozy parce
que progressivement les gens avaient
gardé en tête cette posture d'autorité
ce n'est pas le seul à l'époque c'était
la droite qui était au pouvoir et de ce
point de vue là elle avait bénéficié à
la fois Jacques Chirac et Dominique de
Villepin avait gagné quelques points
dans les sondages et cette fois-ci le
Figaro vient de publier coup sur coup de
sondages un sondage que nous avons
publié ce matin donc avec eux et avec
Fiducial qui dont on reparlera peut-être
sur le rapport des élus et de la
violence on le détaillera et donc qui
qui montre justement que les Français
ont cette cette posture de stylité cette
extrême violence et un sondage fait par
nos confrères de l'Ifop ce week-end qui
montre cette dualité c'est à dire à la
fois de la colère de la tristesse par
rapport à l'incident à l'accident
originel c'est-à-dire le
la mort de la mort la mort de Naël et
des gens qui ont été choqués etc bon et
dans un second temps tout aussi fort une
posture d'incompréhension et de colère
par rapport à une violence que les jupes
Français jugent acceptables et dont il
ne comprennent pas qu'on ne parviennent
pas à se défaire et cette situation
juste dans le sondage de nos confrères
de l'Ifop on voit qu'il teste
différentes personnalités politiques et
celles qui bénéficient le plus
c'est-à-dire qui est jugé la plus
positivement quant à sa posture par
rapport aux événements c'est Marine Le
Pen on y reviendra évidemment sur le les
fait politique à moyen et long terme
Richard Berly a plus court terme comment
vous analysez vous vous demandez un
focus sur l'action du gouvernement et
peut-être la réponse du d'un duo qu'on a
beaucoup entendu le duo Gérald Darmanin
Eric Dupond-Moretti
écoutez si je regarde Emmanuel Macron ce
qu'il a annoncé la manière dont il s'est
comporté il était je crois hier soir ou
avant-hier soir dans un commissariat à
Paris un commissariat de la BAC si je ne
me trompe pas je dirais que Emmanuel
Macron c'est quand même darmanisé il est
il est dans la posture avant tout du
défenseur de l'ordre public et toutes
les paroles d'Emmanuel Macron sont allés
dans ce sens-là dans la dans le sens de
la sécurité ramener d'abord la sécurité
en gros et on discutera après et
justement le temps de la discussion
s'est ouvert avec les mers donc je crois
qu'il y a clairement peut-être que la
posture dont vous parliez va profiter
d'ailleurs à Gérald Darmanin qui incarne
cet aspect sécuritaire au sein du
gouvernement
Eric Dupont-Moretti c'est plus compliqué
parce que Eric Dupond-Moretti on sent
qu'il a une injonction sécuritaire qui
pèse sur lui et d'ailleurs il l'a
transmis au magistrat en disant d'être
sévère notamment pour les comparutions
immédiates mais je peux vous dire pour
être allé dimanche toute l'après-midi au
palais de justice de Nanterre que le
passé simple à mettre d'abord c'est pas
si simple sur le terrain parce que dès
lors que vous judiciarisez les choses
plus complexe et il suffit pas de dire
il faut faire il y a des nécessités
juridiques à respecter et d'autre
partant du côté des avocats et les
anciens collègues dérives Dupont-Moretti
que du côté des juges le fait de voir
Dupont-Moretti qui a été longtemps
l'avocat qui appelait des fonds pour le
doute pour donner aux accusés le
bénéfice du doute c'était ça son
commerce et il l'a fait avec beaucoup de
talent aujourd'hui il dit le contraire
et là il a un problème de casting Éric
Dupond-Moretti se réinventer en grand je
dirais en grand tenant de la répression
c'est quelque chose qui à mon sens en
tout cas dans la corporation judiciaire
ne passe pas l'information principale de
ce 4 juillet on l'a dit en titre c'est
donc cette loi d'urgence annoncée par
Emmanuel Macron pour accélérer la
reconstruction dans les dans les villes
saccagées ou dont certains bâtiments ont
été saccagés on écoute Yann gallumer
divers à gauche de Bourges détaillé les
annonces du chef de l'État
il a fait des annonces sur une loi
d'urgence pour reconstruire donc ça
c'est intéressant
notamment nos bâtiments communaux qui
ont été extrêmement touchés il a annoncé
aussi des crédits spécifiques par
rapport aux dégâts que nous avions eu il
a annoncé un travail avec les assurances
donc on va voir dans les jours qui
viennent comment ça se traduit puis il a
annoncé des grands chantiers
est-ce qu'on a senti qu'il voulait aller
très vite puisqu'il nous adore c'est
déjà à donner rendez-vous pour la fin de
l'été
on l'a entendu dans le sujet d'ouverture
un seul Foucault dans cette réunion il y
a il y a beaucoup d'élus qu'on pris à
partie en tout cas rappeler Emmanuel
Macron qu'il avait enterré le plan le
plan Borlo qui était un plan ambitieux
de politique de de la ville
ce fait particulier ce rappel à lui
aujourd'hui c'est l'une des promesses
non tenues du candidat Macron 2017
oui non c'est vrai que le la proposition
les propositions de Jean-Louis Borloo
qui a été ministre de la Ville et qui
avait fait un travail important pas
simplement dans le le contenu des
propositions mais la méthode notamment
avec les élus on y revient notamment en
dialoguant beaucoup avec les élus mais
aussi j'irai plus largement l'ensemble
des corps intermédiaires y compris les
organisations syndicales parce que sur
les questions de la politique de la
ville il y a aussi un sujet de maillage
du territoire et de l'attractivité
économique de ces territoires moi je
dirais que le plan Borlo 2018
n'est peut-être pas totalement
enterré au regard de ce qui vient de se
passer c'est à dire que ça ne pourra
plus être le plan Borlo mais il va
falloir rapidement sans s'en inspirer il
y a un deuxième élément sa cousine vraie
question pardon c'est que on est dans
une réaction à chaud alors que le plan
Borlo avait justement été pour une fois
elle était fait dans une période plutôt
calme mais avec voilà cette volonté de
dialoguer de prendre oui alors il y a
quand même des il y a quand même eu des
évolutions dans la politique de la ville
depuis la création de cette
pardonnez-moi pour l'acronie mais la NCT
l'Agence nationale de la cohésion des
territoires qui a été fortement mobilisé
pour gérer l'après grand débat national
le mouvement gilets jaunes qui a
commencé à produire des effets notamment
sur je dirais la réelle
occasion des services publics qui
souffrait sur un certain territoire de
d'une profonde disparition voir
déshérence donc il y a eu des évolutions
mais quand on parle de politique de la
ville c'est avant tout pour les
agglomérations et les métropoles parce
que ça ne concerne pas les petites
communes de moins de 10000 habitants et
en entendant notamment le maire de
Bourges je crois qu'il y a deux sujets
une loi d'urgence sur du réparatif au
fond l'état sait faire il s'est dépensé
en urgence je pense que les mers vont
quand même être très prudents parce que
depuis 2017 l'accueil qui est réservé
lorsqu'il s'y présente Emmanuel Macron
au Congrès des Maires l'accueil n'est
pas très chaleureux
et notamment sur la question des
estimant que Emmanuel Macron a décidé de
resserrer la vis en termes de transfert
vers les collectivités mais ce qui me
semble important et je ne sais pas si
Emmanuel Macron va aller dans ce sens
quand on dit il y aura un mouvement de
décentralisation c'est la demande depuis
des années et des années des mers et
notamment de l'association qu'il
représente la ce sont des maires de
France et on voit bien qu'il Emmanuel
Macron dit au fond quelque chose de très
contradictoire oui pour de la
décentralisation on va vous donner des
compétences nouvelles mais non pour les
transferts financiers ou autrement dit
une liberté une autonomie financière
cette capacité à lever l'impôt et moi je
rappelle que à partir dans des
territoires et dans des juridictions
quand on laisse des autorités locales
lever l'impôt on construit la
citoyenneté parce que la question de
l'impôt avec le service public ça fait
société or là il me semble qu'Emmanuel
Macron n'a pas laissé peut-être qu'il
est trop tôt entendre qu'il allait
donner beaucoup d'autonomie financière
j'étais en train d'essayer pour tout
dire de joindre la régie mais ça ne
marche pas donc c'est pas très vous tout
le monde me regarde comme mais qu'est-ce
qu'il fait le présentateur pour qu'il
s'énerve je voudrais qu'on écoute le son
parce que c'est typique c'est exactement
ce dont vous nous parlez on avait prévu
d'entendre une réaction de Fabien
Roussel le secrétaire national du Parti
communiste français qui était ce matin
l'invité des quatre vérités sur France 2
et justement il parle exactement de ça
de ce décalage entre ce qu'on va
promettre au maire là aujourd'hui mais
ce qu'on leur a aussi retiré depuis
quelques années écoute on le
il faut écouter les mers qu'il soit de
droite ou de gauche qui habitent dans
ces grandes villes ce qu'ils ont eu au
titre de la politique de la ville etc ça
compense à peine à peine ce qu'ils ont
perdu ces dernières années en dotation
ça nous répond pas aux besoins qu'ils
ont en matière d'école d'équipements
sportifs culturels
il faut des moyens il faut plus de
moyens il faut de l'argent mais je suis
alerté par des maires y compris des
mères de de communes de petites tailles
en Bretagne dans le sud puisque je les
ai eu au téléphone qui me disent que
parce que ils vont perdre 50 habitants
sur un karting ne vont plus bénéficier
des politiques de la ville ils ne vont
plus être occupés le quartier politique
de la ville ils vont sortir de ces
dispositifs c'est pas normal
la difficulté est d'ailleurs que nous
disait c'est que ça fait quand même des
années des décennies que des milliards
d'euros sont arrivés dans des dans des
cités des favorisés avec une question
vous disiez peut-être que ça a été trop
saupoudré ou trop épisodique qui a pas
eu une vision de long terme et un suivi
suffisant mais aujourd'hui quand dans
l'opinion ça m'intéresse de savoir
comment ces milliards sont perçus est-ce
que ils ont été perdus oubliés détourné
voilà comment on peut en être là
aujourd'hui alors que des dizaines de
milliards d'euros ont été dépensés
depuis 40 ans un pognon de dingue dirait
quelqu'un qu'on connaît l'opinion ne le
comprend pas il y a une fracture dans
l'opinion dans la société entre les gens
qui habitent dans des zones périurbaines
calmes dans des villes calmes et les
gens qui habitent soit dans des
quartiers avec des cités soit à
proximité de celle-ci avec le sentiment
vous avez vu fleurir sur les réseaux
sociaux tout un tas de messages parfois
parfois assez désagréable nauséabonds
suggérant que les casseurs étaient
toujours les mêmes et qu'en gros on
payait les allocations des gens qui
venaient briser les
réaliser les objets publics donc
l'opinion publique et le perçoit très
mal elle se durcit sur ses sur ces
sujets on a un clivage dans la société
qui se renforce une fracture Jacques
Chirac parlait il y a en 95 ça nous ça
nous rajeunit pas il y a presque 30 ans
d'une fracture sociale elle n'a fait que
ce renforcer et la société se cliver
davantage
avec une montée mais on n'est pas le
seul pays pour le coup
martial Foucault doit le mesurer mieux
que moi mais on mesure dans de plus en
plus de pays maintenant cette
fracturation des sociétés avec
avec ce sentiment qu'on a deux pays qui
qui se comprennent plus et puis Richard
Werly a l'un des maires qui était reçu à
l'Élysée aujourd'hui qu'il disait dans
notre sujet d'ouverture ce sentiment
d'une prime au casseurs on enfin voilà
c'est vous avez remarqué c'est peut-être
une réalité des prochaines semaines et
un thème dont on va beaucoup entendre
parler vous avez remarqué que c'était le
maire de Trappes on a beaucoup parlé de
trappes à une époque moi je crois que
c'est une réelle difficulté parce que si
cette situation devait accoucher d'une
loi d'urgence peut-être bien venue par
rapport aux nécessité mais si à cette
occasion on devait lever tous les
verrous qui est préalablement avait
empêché un certain nombre de choses ça
posera quand même de sérieuses questions
parce que on le sait en France et nous
les correspondants étrangers on le voit
souvent casser ça finit toujours par
payer c'est une réalité parce que c'est
un moyen de se faire entendre c'est un
moyen peut-être de se faire respecter en
tout cas c'est un moyen d'obliger la
classe politique d'obliger le système à
agir et si c'est le cas si les milliards
pleuvent maintenant ça ne veut pas dire
qu'il y a pas eu d'argent avant si la
loi d'urgence est adoptée il faudra
quand même réfléchir moins une chose qui
me frappe c'est quand même vous disiez
on parlait de loi Borlo il y a quand
même des fautes politiques pardon mais
le ne pas enfin avoir écarté en plus de
la manière dont ça a été fait si je me
souviens bien le rapport Borlo c'est
quand même on peut parler de fautes
politiques de la part d'Emmanuel Macron
à l'époque la deuxième chose c'est ce
que disent les mères le fait que les qui
sont au fond coincé moi ça me fera
beaucoup à chaque fois que je leur parle
y compris ces dernières années y compris
sur de tout autre sujet comme le sujet
de l'islamisme par exemple qu'est-ce que
disait les mers on est coincé parce que
on est coincé entre d'une part notre
population on se doit d'avoir une paix
sociale dans nos communes donc de faire
des compromis et d'autre part par l'État
qui nous met des injonctions en
permanence et qui nous refusent les
budgets pour agir et donc les maires ils
sont entre ces deux obligations et ils
le vivent très mal et c'est ce qu'on
voit à nouveau aujourd'hui Émilie moi
j'ai l'impression que c'est aussi
symptomatique des réactions d'Emmanuel
Macron face aux crises on a quand même
des réactions qui sont courtes alors on
comprend cette idée de sécurité qui est
demandée par la majorité de la
population on peut pas passer outre on
comprend l'idée de la reconstruction et
là on entend il faut aller vite les
grands chantiers seront annoncés après
l'été on est quand même à la sixième
année de pouvoir d'Emmanuel Macron on a
un président qui en tant que candidat
d'ailleurs je crois qu'il a fait faire
acte de candidature à Bobigny en
piochant sur cet voilà sur cette
électorat qu'il pensait plutôt favorable
des jeunes entrepreneurs Hubert et
compagnie des gens qui pourraient
éventuellement mettre sous sa coupe il a
vite compris je pense que ça saluait un
peu et que c'était peut-être pas
nécessaire d'investir beaucoup je pense
que le plan Barolo à la poubelle alors
la raison invoquée c'était de mal blanc
ne vont pas régler la question des
quartiers prioritaires
Emmanuel Macron je pense que peut-être
que c'était pas la solution le plan
borlou est peut-être qu'il y avait des
bonnes choses et des choses de moins
intéressantes mais ça a été très
symbolique et toutes ces actions qui
auraient été plus de long terme ne sont
jamais enfin sont rarement utilisés par
Emmanuel Macron et là on a quand même
une réponse sécurité reconstruction et
puis après l'été alors que le diagnostic
comme vous l'avez dit par les maires et
quand même fait depuis longtemps ça
viendra que après et juste une remarque
les banlieues n'étaient pas présentes
aux gilet jaune n'était pas présent de
retraite donc on s'en occupe pas tant
que ça bouge pas et là tout d'un coup il
y a émeute il en la demeure et on active
les solutions alors on va s'appuyer sur
votre dernier baromètre au doxa sur le
j'ai pris deux éléments qui moi me
semble vraiment très intéressant après
donc l'attaque contre le domicile et la
famille de Vincent Jean Brun le maire de
L'Haÿ-les-Roses vous avez interrogé les
Français sur ce thème d'abord sur la
crainte d'une crise de l'engagement
républicain ça je trouve ça intéressant
la question si vous souhaitiez vous
présenter à une élection pourriez-vous y
renoncer par crainte pour votre sécurité
ou celle de votre famille oui et je
précise Thomas que c'est encore plus
intéressant parce que le sondage
l'enquête a été réalisé avant la TAG du
domicile de Vincent Jean Brun
c'est-à-dire que alors même mais on
avait malheureusement il y avait eu
Saint-Brevin il y avait eu il y avait eu
tout un tas d'éléments qui légitimaient
la pertinence de ce sujet avec nos
partenaires de Fiducial on réalise ce
baromètre régulièrement donc c'est
quelque chose qu'on suit dans le temps
et effectivement vous avez en parallèle
avec la crise d'évocation des maires
vous avez 80% des des Français qui nous
disent que ça pourrait les dissuader de
ce de se lancer dans une carrière d'élus
le fait d'être de sentir les élus de
plus en plus menacés on en a 86% qui
nous disent les maires sont de plus en
plus menacés sont beaucoup plus menacées
qu'auparavant et ensuite on en a 66%
pardon les deux tiers qui nous disent
ben moi si j'envisageais une carrière
d'élus c'est ce qu'on voit ici 66 et
bien ça pourrait me dissuader de me
présenter je rappelle qu'une crise
d'évocation qui est sans précédent et
une enquête de l'association des maires
de France qui montrait aussi une une
intention de ce non représenté qui était
absolument record et alors il y a une
autre un autre élément que je trouve
intéressant sur le les demandes de
sanctions plus lourdes contre ceux qui
visent les élus et là la question c'est
à propos de la mesure renforçant les
sanctions pénales pour les auteurs de
violence faite aux élus on les alignant
sur celles faites au personnel en
uniformes favorable ou non 80% donc on a
il y a un consensus absolu pour
considérer alors les Français sont un
peu difficiles sur leur rapport aux élus
ils n'ont pas tous la même la même cote
et pas tous la même ne bénéficient pas
tous de la même volonté de les protéger
parce que quand on les interroge sur les
ministres les parlementaires etc ils ont
l'impression que ça va alors que des
parlementaires des des permanences
saccagées ça existe aussi mais en tout
cas il y a ce sentiment qu'il faut
instamment protéger nos élus
Marcel Foucault en quelques mots c'est
encore beaucoup de thèmes à aborder on
le disait déjà il y a quelques semaines
après Saint-Brevin la démission du maire
etc la probabilité de d'avoir une sorte
de pénurie de candidats aux municipales
est-ce que vous y croyez ou pas
je pense que ce sujet revient un peu
comme
la vie municipale c'est-à-dire que
concrètement ça veut dire quoi sur 35
000 communes nous avons depuis 2001 une
soixantaine de communes qui vont
rencontrer des difficultés pour avoir
des listes complètes à déposer en
préfecture d'accord je rappelle que on
est le seul pays au monde capable tant
d'une élection municipale de rassembler
près de 1 million de citoyens rassemblés
sur l'ensemble des listes électorales
sur un corps électoral de 47 millions de
personnes c'est unique certes Scellier
au fait qu'on a 35 ans
véritablement une crise de vocation on
aurait effectivement énormément de
communes dans l'incapacité de pouvoir
présenter des listes donc je ne veux pas
sous-estimer les effets que produisent
le contexte actuel et les violences qui
sont en progression en revanche on
arrive à une période charnière dans le
mandat municipal on sait mandat et nous
sommes à mi-mandat en 2023 c'est là où
on atteint toujours le pic des
démissions donc dans les prochaines
semaines on va continuer de parler d'un
grand nombre de démissions et puis vous
verrez au fur et à mesure qu'on se
rapproche de l'échéance l'intention de
ne pas se représenter ou de démissionner
va s'estomper au fur et à mesure qu'on
se rapproche de l'élection municipale de
vos articles vous dites que le les
maires sont d'une sorte de de au centre
d'une sorte de spirale de
méprisiez tout à l'heure il y a un
deuxième impact possible peut-être que
les candidats comme vous le dites on en
trouvera de toute manière et que le
nombre de volontaires pour des fonctions
électives va ré augmenter mais leur
volonté d'agir leur volonté de faire
face à la population leur volonté au
fond de se faire des adversaires de se
faire des ennemis au sein de leur
population leur volonté de mécontenté
parce que quand on est élu il faut le
faire c'est peut-être ça qui va être
touché au fond un élu un élu qui fait
son travail c'est un élu qui prend des
responsabilités qui prend des choix qui
les assument et là je pense qu'à un
certain de mer peuvent être tentés vu le
contexte de gérer les affaires courantes
oui non parce qu'on a eu un bel exemple
pendant l'automne crise énergétique on
avait interrogé l'ensemble des 35000
mers et j'avais été frappé de voir que
sur toutes les mesures visant à
atteindre la sobriété et des économies
d'énergie les mères indiquées nous
allons réduire l'éclairage nous allons
fermer un certain nombre d'installations
et on leur posait la question est-ce que
vous allez consulter l'ensemble des
citoyens à 90% les maires non on ne
consulte pas sur ces sujets on assume
nos délivions d'accord donc ce que je
veux dire par là
quand vous fermez des établissements
culturels sportifs quand vous réduisez
l'éclairage la nuit vous pouvez
provoquer quand même la compréhension
donc ça c'est une première partie et
puis rapidement il y a aussi gérer le
contraire c'est à dire que beaucoup de
maires et je vous rejoins sont souvent
dans la recherche d'un compromis quand
bien même cela vient en porte-à-faux
d'initiative ou de projets qu'ils
avaient égrainés pendant la campagne se
disent là je vais créer des tensions et
je refuse les tensions dans ma
municipalité parce que au fond je n'ai
pas les moyens personnels ou les moyens
de l'État pour pouvoir affronter de
telle tension on va passer de la
politique locale à la politique
nationale avec les propositions faites
par différents partis politiques et
aussi les conséquences de ces nuits à
Pasquier on va commencer par le
rassemblement national au milieu de des
événements des réactions Le Pen elle
joue la carte de la sobriété
avec ce qu'elle avait fait dans la
campagne moins j'en dis mieux je me
porte c'est un peu comme ça qu'on
pourrait résumer la stratégie qu'elle
choisit Marine Le Pen ne cherchez pas
des tweets n'ont pas finir de la députée
du Pas-de-Calais au lendemain du
tragique évènement elle se contente
d'une réponse assez courte aux médias et
d'un tweet sobre pour souligner
l'attitude irresponsable qu'elle juge
irresponsable du gouvernement et pour
critiquer aussi l'appel au désordre de
la France insoumise est-ce qu'on peut
dire que l'histoire se répète là oui
parce que de l'autre côté il y a Éric
Zemmour qui s'excite un petit peu sur
les thèmes de l'immigration il fait tout
de suite le lien donc comme pour la
présidentielle 2022
Eric Zemmour lui sert de paratonnerre
sur ses thèmes là qui sont finalement
toujours les fondamentaux du
rassemblement national mais qu'elle n'a
pas besoin de ressortir lui il le fait à
sa place il y a Éric sotti aussi qui
prend le relais dans ce rôle là puisque
chef de républicain il a demandé comme
Éric Zemmour l'état d'urgence tout de
suite illico presto et il a étendu aussi
son propos sanction qu'il fallait donner
aux émeutiers aux allocations qu'il
fallait retirer aux familles de ces
émeutiers des axes qui d'ailleurs
inspirent un petit peu le gouvernement
et Marine Le Pen elle fait le choix de
s'exprimer plus tard plutôt à froid elle
s'exprime à froid c'était le vendredi de
la semaine et dernière dans une elle
fait une vidéo qui est postée sur les
réseaux sociaux où elle est plus sobre
que jamais plus présidentiable que
jamais le cadre et léché on a le drapeau
français on a le bureau de la future
présidente le ton est posé elle prône le
retour à l'ordre républicain on l'écoute
comme responsable de la première force
d'opposition
j'entends m'en tenir à la ligne de
conduite qui est la nôtre de ne rien
faire qui puisse empêcher ou entraver
l'action des autorités légitimes qui ont
en charge l'ordre public
j'apporte tout mon soutien à l'ensemble
des forces de sécurité déployées pour
faire cesser ses émeutes alors ne rien
faire ne rien dire comme le souligne
loin d'elle l'idée donc de faire des
amalgames directes avec l'immigration ni
même d'appeler donc le gouvernement à
passer illico à l'état d'urgence elle
choisit une posture beaucoup plus
pondérée elle appelle à l'ordre elle
remercier aussi les forces de police qui
tiennent bon elle demande à Emmanuel
Macron de recevoir les parties
d'opposition représentées à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est une attitude qui est
assez cohérente avec ce qui se passe sur
les bancs de l'Assemblée avec les 88
députés rassemblements national cravate
au coup calme apparent parce qu'il y a
eu quand même quelques débordements
souviens de Grégoire de Fournas qui le
retourne en Afrique et puis des tweets
un petit peu à relents
identitaires on voit que c'est de la
communication mais si Marine Le Pen
arrive à jouer ainsi avec une hauteur de
vue et l'appel à l'ordre républicain
c'est aussi parce que ces petits soldats
et Jordan Bardella en premier lieu
développe une approche qui est
complémentaire et qui est bien plus
agressive on l'écoute tout de suite dans
une de ces dernières sorties je pense
qu'un nouveau plan banlieue dans ces
conditions seraient un cadeau fait aux
émeutiers absolument inouï et un signal
de laxisme désastreux à l'encontre de
gens qui ont défi l'autorité de l'État
et qui se considère impuni par la
justice de notre pays donc on voit bien
le duo du modéré pour Marine Le Pen du
beaucoup plus agressif pour Jordan
Bardella et s'il en croit les sondages
ça marche quand même puisque les
sondages places Marine Le Pen en
favorite de la présidentielle 2027 donc
c'est de la politique fiction mais c'est
quand même à signaler mais payant
jusqu'à quand moi je me suis posé la
question est-ce que la prochaine future
candidate à l'élection suprême en tout
cas potentielle probable est-ce qu'elle
pourra rester comme ça planquer
éternellement derrière cette posture se
mit silencieuse à ne rien dire ne rien
faire essayez de récolter les fruits de
ce silence à chaque fois finalement
qu'elle est sortie du bois on a vu
l'effet immédiat fragilité beaucoup de
faiblesses sur un certain nombre de
thématiques en termes de solutions
retours des mauvais réflexes et
finalement et peut-être d'ailleurs que
le nom Le Pen y est encore pour beaucoup
un louper à peu de votre prêt c'est vrai
mais un loupé quand même pour se faire
élire présidente Slimane vous l'avez dit
rapidement tout à l'heure mais si on
rentre un peu dans le détail elle
engrange Marine Le Pen alors c'est je
dois citer un sondage qui n'est pas un
sondage odoxa mais le sondage
Ifop publié par par notre partenaire du
Figaro ce week-end montrer poser une
question sur les différentes
personnalités politiques et leur posture
pendant les émeutes déjà quand même un
premier élément une majorité de français
pour chaque personnalité politique d'y
être mécontente ou insatisfaite de la
posture de cette personnalité donc tout
le monde s'en sort mal celle qui s'en
sort le moins mal parmi toutes les
personnalités testées c'est Le Pen de
mémoire elle doit être à 39% de
personnes qui se disent satisfaites de
sa posture à titre de comparaison de
mémoire Macron et d'armanin sont à 33 34
donc ça fait quand même 5 à 6 points de
plus que le Président de la République
est le ministre de l'intérieur par
ailleurs je rejoins ce que vous avez dit
les uns et les autres on a l'impression
de revivre avec des scénarios un petit
peu différents mais les le même film
puisque on a vécu ça avec les gilets
jaunes on a vécu ça avec la réforme des
retraites à chaque fois on est dans une
situation où on a un président de la
République qui donne le sentiment d'être
trop lointain dans sa tour d'ivoire qui
ne voit pas arriver le problème qui qui
discute peu avec les les partenaires
sociaux ou avec les corps intermédiaires
ça implose et puis on voit Marine Le Pen
en tirer les bénéfices dans les enquêtes
d'opinion ça s'est passé aussi pour la
réforme des retraite qui est toute
récente et où on avait deux postures
distinctes celles de des insoumis et de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon on l'avait testé dans
notre baromètre politique on avait parlé
ici qui était sur une posture très
vindic
très en phase avec l'opinion publique
qui était très hostile à cette réforme
des retraites et résultat quand on sonde
les Français ils nous disent bah j'ai
préféré la posture de Marine Le Pen à
celle de Jean-Luc Mélenchon durant cette
réforme des retraites et très
vraisemblablement ça va être encore le
cas cette fois-ci alors on va continuer
de justement d'évaluer en rentrant un
peu plus dans le détail des propositions
faites par notamment l'assemblement
national et elle est fiche propose à
Audrey beta de nous rejoindre sur ce
plateau bon soit Audrey bienvenue à vous
est-ce que vous diriez que les partis
politiques sont s'engagent là dans une
sorte de surenchère législative un petit
peu comme à chaque événement marquant la
réponse politique ne se fait pas
attendre depuis une semaine les
propositions se multiplient dans tous
les camps sur tous les thèmes le
rassemblement national vous l'avez
évoqué vient de déposé un texte à
l'Assemblée pour supprimer l'excuse de
minorité expliquant je cite les mineurs
capables de discernement doivent être
pénalement responsables des crimes
délits ou contraventions dont ils ont
été reconnus coupables alors la réponse
du garde des sceaux Eric Dupond-Moretti
ne s'est pas fait attendre c'était cet
après-midi lors des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
l'excuse de minorité si vous y revenez
je vous indique tout de suite que le
Conseil constitutionnel vous censurera
monsieur le député c'est tout à fait
clair parce que le Conseil
constitutionnel souhaite qu'on fasse une
différence entre les mineurs et les
majeurs et je pense que certains peuvent
ici retrouver mais le RN n'est pas le
seul groupe politique à céder à une
sorte de pression législative la France
insoumise et les républicains ont aussi
fait des propositions alors chacun dans
leur couloir par contre
nous avons proposé d'abroger la
disposition d'hypermétuer dans la loi
Cazeneuve de 2017 nous avons proposé de
faire en sorte que systématiquement
comme le demande le Syndicat de la
magistrature soit dépaysé les affaires
de violence policière plus que jamais
cette question de la responsabilité des
parents qui existent dans le Code civil
et dans le code pénal doit être mise à
oeuvre la loi qui sanctionne ce défaut
d'autorité l'absentéisme scolaire par
notamment la suppression des allocations
familiales doit être votée et le Sénat
n'est pas en reste alors au Sénat ce
sont les violences contre les mers qui
ont beaucoup choqué et les sénateurs de
rappeler qu'ils ont des idées pour
protéger les élus vous en avez parlé un
exemple une proposition de loi François
Noel buffet le président LR de la
commission des lois est inscrite au
bureau du Sénat depuis le 26 mai dernier
il appelle l'exécutif à son emparer
alors cette mesure consiste notamment à
aligner les sanction s contre quelqu'un
qui s'en prendrait à un maire avec celle
encourus si on s'en prend à un policier
ou un magistrat soit 50 prisons et 75000
euros d'amende autre texte qui était
dans les cartons et qui vient d'être
déposé aujourd'hui une proposition de
loi socialiste cette fois-ci pour créer
un statut d'élus pour mieux les protéger
puisque la moitié des mers consacre en
réalité plus de 35 heures à leur mandat
écoutez
proposons la création d'un statut
particulier d'agent civique territorial
qui ferait que tout mère dans des
communes d'une certaine strat serait
obligatoirement placé sous ce statut qui
leur permettrait d'être rémunéré d'avoir
des droits à la retraite d'avoir les
droits sociaux et de se consacrer
pleinement à l'exercice de leur mandat
d'autre part nous souhaitons
systématiser la protection fonctionnelle
de façon automatique pour tous les élus
dès lors qu'ils sont mis en cause dans
le cadre de leurs fonctions et enfin
nous souhaitons puisque beaucoup
d'attaques maintenant se font via les
réseaux sociaux allongé la prescription
de trois mois à un an pour avoir le
temps de mener les enquêtes nécessaires
voilà pour les réponses immédiates mais
il y en a aussi qui appelle à une
réflexion sur le temps long c'est le cas
de Patrick canner le patron des
sénateurs socialistes au Sénat lui
demande un débat parlementaire sur les
événements qui ont eu lieu après la mort
de Naël il n'a pas encore eu de réponse
pour l'instant de la première merci
beaucoup Audrey vettaz martial Foucault
peut-être une analyse un peu en
parallèle ou en miroir des deux des deux
blocs d'opposition que ce soit on va
dire la droite ou les droites et la
nupesse est-ce que les deux blocs sont
d'après vous
dérivent vers les extrêmes est-ce que
c'est à ça qu'on assiste depuis
plusieurs mois est-ce que c'est renforcé
par la séquence que l'on est en train de
quand on écoute les propositions des
chefs de parties ou des responsables de
parties que ce soit la France insoumise
les républicains rassemblement national
finalement on a quelque chose de très
classique on est sur un registre à
droite renforcement de l'ordre
j'allais même inflation répressive sur à
la fois les peines et je ne parle pas de
l'excuse de minorité qui revient comme
je dirais à chaque événement ou des
mineurs se retrouvent finalement au cœur
de l'actualité puis à gauche c'est tout
l'inverse on n'est pas du tout sur un
registre de l'ordre et presque de la
répression mais on est finalement sur
une accusation d'une police qui serait
responsable des événements et la France
insoumise a eu une position très
particulière c'est dernier jour à ce
propos en revanche en janvier pas que la
loi en question elle s'appelle Cazeneuve
donc absolument
une majorité de gauche avec une majorité
de gauche un moment où le nombre de
frondeurs au sein de cette gauche était
déjà importé
et puis quand à la question aussi
intéressante la position des sénateurs
qu'on entend ici en disant il faut
remettre la question du statut de l'élu
faisons attention parce que je pense que
c'est ces recettes dans le temps très
très court parce qu'on doit proposer on
est dans la réactivité le statut l'élu
s'il s'agit de professionnaliser la
fonction de maire alors on va créer une
situation qui aujourd'hui préserver en
quelque chose en quelque sorte cette
démocratie municipale parce que c'était
des mères bénévoles je rappelle c'est 34
000 maires dans des communes de moins de
habitants qui sont des quasiment des
bénévoles et pour beaucoup d'entre eux
ils ont une activité professionnelle à
côté et si on professionnelle de la vie
professionnalisme parlons la vie
politique même municipale alors on va
introduire instaurer une nouvelle
relation entre les élus et leur
représentants aujourd'hui si les mers
sont les représentants préférés des
français en qui ils ont confiance et
précisément parce que ce ne sont pas des
professionnels de la politique donc
attention aux recettes miracle dans un
temps j'avais une petite tristesse en
voyant ce paysage politique un
sincèrement parce que j'ai l'impression
qu'il y a d'un côté donc Emmanuel Macron
au cours termiste et on a quand même des
caricatures un petit peu à côté de la
plaque que ça soit à gauche enfin
extrême gauche ou à droite on sent
qu'ils sont à côté de la plaque quand
même revoir la loi 2017 pourquoi pas
mais c'est pas enfin c'est pas l'urgence
là les sanctions sur les parents
alors la rengaine toujours de la
responsabilité des parents je trouve que
c'est très caricatural et c'est très
pauvre en fait en proposition qui serait
un peu construite qui serait un petit
peu plus loin à la limite bon pourquoi
pas un débat de fond suite aux émeutes
ça ça peut être la seule proposition qui
est intéressante et en face en effet
encore une fois on a l'URN qui dit rien
qui fait rien et qui récupère tout ça
parce que la droite comme la gauche il
me semble n'est pas à la hauteur de la
situation à l'heure actuelle il pêche
par manque je sais pas de travail de
d'idées de figure je sais pas ce qu'il y
a mais il y a un problème et c'est quand
même un sujet des banlieues dont on
parle depuis très longtemps on connaît
quand même même si le diagnostic comme
vous l'avez dit il y a peut-être pas été
le bon mais on sait que c'est du
logement service public la police aussi
il y a quand même plusieurs aspects qui
sont reconnus et là on nous sort des
recettes soi-disant miracle qui sont un
peu caricatural Richard vernis si
c'était bon si c'était simple on a je
pense que la solution aurait été sans
doute été trouvé depuis plusieurs
décennies mais moi je voudrais terminer
parce que vous avez signé plusieurs
articles publics il y en qui est assez
frappant sur la réaction des mers des
élus
quand ils voient les ce qu'on peut
appeler les biens communs c'est-à-dire
ce qui a été construit justement pour
les populations de de ces quartiers des
favorisés détruit par certains enfants
certains enfants de ces quartiers des
favorisés comment ça c'est le syndrome
qui se résume dans la phrase que l'on
m'a dit on construit on nous casse la
gueule donc voilà on se dépense pour
construire et en échange on cherche à
nous casser la gueule donc je crois
qu'il y a chez beaucoup de mer d'abord
une incompréhension il y a beaucoup de
mères qui découvrent il faut quand même
le dire aussi des situations qu'ils ne
pensaient pas être aussi graves ils sont
eux-mêmes surpris par les événements et
ils découvrent aussi le je dirais
l'impuissance de l'action publique
puisque infini ce que vous produisez en
termes d'investissement et bien ne
parvient pas à pacifier et de ce point
de vue là moi je trouve que quand même
je reviens juste à Marine Le Pen elle
marque un but elle marque un point sur
le fait qu'elle fait une intervention
rassurante elle elle
elle elle dit simplement je fais
confiance je fais confiance aux forces
de l'ordre et à l'état pour assurer le
bon le retour à une situation normale et
se faire confiance alors que beaucoup
d'autres sont anxiogènes ça ça peut
jouer vraiment un rôle et ça peut lui
apporter un certain crédit je ne dis pas
que alors il y a pas de solution c'est
vrai il y a pas de proposition mais le
faire confiance c'est quand même venant
d'elle et bien là il faut reconnaître
qu'elle a une parole qui est différente
des autres on termine là-dessus merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat et à bientôt sur sur public
c'est